[Music]
on this thursday night
one month later one percent inoculated
what's being promised to boost the
vaccine campaign as some provinces run
out of doses
we're relying on the federal government
to do its uh best
calls for paid sick leave how better
benefits could help control the spread
of covet 19.
washington d.c ramps up security what
joe biden is being urged to do
on his inauguration day as president
trump's supporters vow to fight on
it's not over plus spreading hate in
canada
the influence of the proud boys and
other far right groups
in this country
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it has now been one month since the
first covid19 vaccinations got underway
the federal government says it is making
good progress on buying vaccines
millions of doses have been ordered
hundreds of thousands have been
delivered but getting them into the arms
of canadians
is slow going according to the
university of toronto's vaccine tracker
as of the last
night roughly 420 000 doses had been
administered
that works out to just over one percent
of the canadian population
it is up to the provinces to administer
them and some premiers say they don't
have enough
doses some regions are now delaying
giving the required
second dose so they can get the first
shot into as many people as possible
abigail beeman has our top story on the
push to pick up the pace
called the ramp up phase the ramp up
phase phase two for vaccination in
canada
anticipated to average more than a
million doses a week
for both currently approved vaccines
starting in april
but right now in the much slower phase
one some provinces are critical of the
roll
out as they run out even with more doses
coming in
alberta premier jason kenney putting it
bluntly we need more shipments of
vaccines
now we're relying on the federal
government to do its
best to make sure that we have a product
here that scarcity is still a challenge
and again i'm not
i'm not throwing any rocks here both
things can be true
there may be a modest supply of vaccine
and vaccine not moving quickly enough
going that that's going out and with the
modest supply quebec has been under fire
for not committing to the second dose
timeline
recommended by the manufacturers 21 days
for pfizer biontech
28 for moderna thursday the province
made a new promise
our expert recommended that the second
dose of the vaccine
be given between 42 and 90 days
in our context this is the best strategy
because we have to deal with very few
vaccines recognizing supply challenges
the national advisory committee on
immunization has updated its timeline
guidelines but not suggesting as big a
window as quebec
preferably within 42 days but i would
like to emphasize
that nasty's core recommendation is that
the complete two dose vaccination series
follow the authorized schedules the
johnson and johnson vaccine only needs
one dose and this week the company said
it's on track to roll it out by
march but no word yet from ottawa about
how close
regulators are to approving it or the
astrazeneca vaccine
abigail beeman global news ottawa
a new stay-at-home order is now in place
in canada's largest province and an
alert
has gone out warning people
that's what buzzed on cell phones in
ontario this morning a reminder that
people must only leave their homes for
essential reasons
there is an exception for people who
have to go to work thousands of
canadians of course work in essential
service jobs for them working from home
is not an option
and if they get sick many don't get paid
according to a canadian health advocacy
group
58 of workers in canada have no access
to paid sick days if they feel sick
staying home
might mean running out of money for rent
and food
as mike derlay reports that's why
there's a big push for paid
sick leave for everyone in grocery
stores in restaurants
long-term care homes and hospitals
frontline workers have been a constant
throughout the pandemic
they've showed up for work regularly but
rashev brown says they never really had
a choice
even though we're going through this
pandemic if you call in sick there's
still chances that
your next shift that you could be
disciplined and now health officials are
drawing a direct line from the lack of
paid sick days to workplace outbreaks
and brown says they all know it so you
need every
single paycheck to survive so you're
basically putting yourself in a position
where
it's either um i can't pay a rent
properly for the month
is either my sacrifice and groceries
this week um
or i stay home because i'm not feeling
well the issue of paid sick days is
complicated
and for the provinces potentially
expensive the issue is of course that
by legislating workplaces to pay this
type of
sick leave you're incurring a new cost
for employers that they didn't have
and so in the middle of a pandemic i
think the provinces have said we're not
willing to do that
so the federal government stepped in and
created the canada recovery sickness
benefit
but as the number of coveted 19 cases
rose sharply since september
so too should have the number of crsb
applicants
yet the opposite occurred why well
critics suggest the crsb is flawed
the benefit pays 450 a week after taxes
which is less than minimum wage there's
no job security for workers
and payments can take four weeks to
process local health officials and
politicians
have been clamoring for a new plan i'm
almost to the hair lighting on fire time
with this where the fact there has been
no
response from anybody about this is it
fair to say that it's going to be
extremely difficult to get coveted under
control
until we solve this key issue yes and
and one of the things that we have to
look at is
when this has worked is when we provided
the most help when we had serb in place
when we had
financial supports in place when people
could stay at home
they did and it shows that public policy
when done the right way works
microlight global news toronto
saskatchewan has the most active cases
of covid19 per capita in canada right
now
that province's top doctor is warning
new restrictions may be needed
today saskatchewan recorded 312 new
infections there are 206 covet 19
patients
in saskatchewan hospitals 33 of them are
in intensive care
that is the highest number since the
pandemic began
and those numbers could skyrocket
according to new modeling if people
don't follow public health guidelines
saskatchewan could see
up to sixteen hundred new cases a day in
the coming weeks
now to washington dc where security for
next week's inauguration is ramping up
to be the most intense in history
members of the national guard are posted
inside and outside the u.s capitol and
on the streets surrounding it
as many as 20 000 troops are expected to
arrive in the coming days
the most ever deployed there the public
has been told to stay away
presidential inaugurations are usually
patriotic displays of the peaceful
transition of power
this time the goal is simply to get
through it without any violence
jackson proskow reports behind fences
and under armed guard the stately u.s
capitol is now a fortress
ringed by layers of security and razor
wire
at a time of extreme domestic threat
the potential for violence to disrupt
the inauguration is considered so
high the national mall where crowds
would normally gather
may be closed to the public the national
guard is on alert for improvised
explosive devices and weapons
members of congress are urging
president-elect joe biden to take the
oath of office
indoors i for one would much rather see
it done
inside for security purposes in the
rotunda
or in the hall of the house sitter is
laid upon the
table the second impeachment of
president donald trump is doing nothing
to quell the anger of his loyal
supporters
i unequivocally condemned the violence
in scripted remarks
trump called for peace violence and
vandalism have
absolutely no place in our country but
he has refused to back down from his
lies about a stolen election
or acknowledge the legitimacy of joe
biden's win
and trump's closest advisers are pouring
fuel onto the fire
the democratic party did violence to
this country
by attacking a president who i believe
was
legally elected on november 3rd
at the same time the fbi warns the
january 6th storming of the capital is
seen as a rallying cry by the far right
pro-trump message boards are filled with
calls for a repeat on inauguration day
it's a long-term threat that will not
end with trump's exit
a wide scale domestic terror movement
but this is going to be a problem that's
going to be with us for
months and years ahead
private companies are now wary of being
used to facilitate any future violence
airbnb has canceled all reservations in
and around the washington area during
next week's inauguration
several airlines are taking measures as
well including banning passengers from
checking guns in their checked baggage
and they're also implementing new rules
that require passengers to stay
seated during the last hour of the
flight before arrival here in washington
donna jackson there's been lots of talk
about who president trump might pardon
before he leaves office that it might
include himself
what do we know about that
plenty of speculation that a whole bunch
of pardons are coming before trump
leaves office for a number of reasons
one it lets him change the channel from
all that impeachment talk of the past
few days
number two it's a sign of his enduring
power here even in his final days in
office
and number three it's a chance for him
to reinforce his agenda at the last
minute
by pardoning friends who've seen him
through these very tough days in his
administration
lots to watch for jackson prosco in
washington thank you
a new american intelligence briefing is
warning the attack on the us capital as
part of an ongoing trend of extremists
exploiting protests to carry out
ideologically motivated violence
the fbi has said white supremacists pose
the greatest domestic terror threat in
the u.s
that threat does not stop at the u.s
border extremists are thriving here in
canada too
the founder of the proud boys is
canadian and as heather urix west
reports the group has
active chapters here this week's a great
audience as well
for months now hundreds of people have
gathered in downtown calgary each week
to protest
kovit 19 restrictions among those
attending on this december day
members of the white nationalist group
the proud boys
last month global news asked calgary's
police chief if this was a concern
i think the thing we're really keying on
is the behavior while in attendance
and for the most part i think this is
the 10th rally that we've
had since around august in relation to
the
the marches for freedom and all of them
have been actually really
quite positive and we haven't had a lot
of issues but their presence hit a nerve
with calgary city councilor jody gondek
in december she said in a tweet i'm
broken today
soldiers of odin walked the streets of
my city filled with hate for people like
me
while so many silently watch it happen
everything starts
somewhere and everything starts small
and then if you
give it the opportunity and the oxygen
it gets bigger
gondek believes what happened a few
weeks later in washington
is proof we are not safe from what's
happening in the united states
exactly the opposite we've contributed
to it the proud boys a group tied to the
attack on the capitol building was
founded by canadian gavin mcinnis
there are chapters in every canadian
city we also
have to keep in mind there are a lot of
individuals
that don't necessarily affiliate with
proud boys or other similar groups but
are very much engaging with their social
media
platforms as the federal government
works to determine whether the proud
boys should be formally designated as a
terrorist organization
many of their online platforms have now
gone dark
but experts warn that these groups grow
their ranks by exploiting the anger of
others
and right now at the height of canada's
second wave
the anger among many is intense people
are angry
about these these lockdowns they're
angry about being required to wear masks
all of those pieces
so there's so many grievances coming
together it's like a it's like a you
know a boiling pot
making canada no less vulnerable than
our neighbors
heather urex west global news calgary
losing the u.s election has made some
trump supporters even more steadfast
coming up we'll head to pennsylvania to
hear how voters are still standing by
their man
plus a legal victory for survivors
abused at mount castle orphanage
decades ago
it's been decades since canada's biggest
sex abuse scandal was first exposed
more than 300 boys were physically and
sexually abused by members of the
christian brothers
at the mount castle orphanage in
newfoundland and labrador
those who survived it are still fighting
the catholic church over it
today the supreme court of canada
rejected an appeal by the church
leaving it liable to pay as ross lord
reports it is the end of a painstaking
process
for victims for more than four decades
physical and sexual abuse at
newfoundland's mount casual orphanage
was suppressed
by a code of silence a cover-up that
finally ended in 1989. then i felt a
pain some survivors have since received
compensation
but others are still pursuing justice
including this 80-year-old man
and three others who are identified
legally as john doe
he was physically and sexually abused
over an eight-year period
ending in 1955. sexual abuse
at night thunder come to ubaid and
they do what they i know i won't
describe it in detail
but they were sexual abuse
and uh the physical was horrendous
the top court's decision leaves the
catholic church in saint john's
on the hook for compensating survivors
the church
helped the christian brothers establish
the orphanage what the big thing about
the decision
is that people in higher authority
have decided that the catholic church
the episcopal corporation
were guilty of negligence
in their duty toward the boys among
casual
and that's the big thing lawyers for the
four men say they stand to receive a
total of two million dollars
the door is now open for more than 50
other survivors to claim compensation
men who struggled all their lives with
education employment
and relationships so we're talking
potential damages
well into the tens of millions of
dollars the catholic archdiocese of
saint john's argued
it should not have to pay compensation
because the christian brothers were a
separate entity
in a statement the archdiocese says it
will review and analyze the court ruling
it says the church has immense sympathy
for those who suffered abuse
at the mount castle orphanage the
orphanage was demolished almost 30 years
ago
the land has been repurposed but
survivors suggest what happened here
will never
be erased ross lord global news
still ahead new revelations about a
suspected mole
in the rcmp
after months of repeated requests
diplomatic disputes and delays
a team of investigators from the world
health organization has arrived in china
their goal is to investigate the origin
of the novel coronavirus
first detected in wuhan china it's not
clear what they'll be given access to
the team must now quarantine for two
weeks and will begin work online
china has continued to reject calls for
an independent probe and
theories on the origins of the pandemic
have become highly politicized by both
beijing
and washington china has allowed the two
michaels limited contact with their
families more than two years after they
were detained
michael spavor made his first phone call
home over christmas
michael kovrig was also allowed a call
to family over the holidays
he'd previously been allowed to speak to
his ailing father
just briefly a spokesperson for the
foreign affairs minister revealed to
global news that canada
obtained agreements in recent months for
what they call increased
family and consular access for the two
michaels the two men were detained
shortly after the arrest of huawei's
chief financial officer mong wang zhou
in vancouver in december 2018 canada has
allowed family members of mong wang zhou
to fly
to canada to visit her global news has
uncovered exclusive new details about a
former
our senior rcmp intelligence chief
accused of leaking government secrets
cameron ortiz was arrested in ottawa in
september 2019
and charged with violating the security
of information act
it's alleged he was preparing to share a
classified information
in 2015 ordis allegedly offered to sell
rcmp special operations plans
to people with suspected links to
pakistani national
altaf hanani's network at the time he
was one of the world's most wanted
money launderers many of his
transactions helped arm and finance
terrorist organizations
including hezbollah and al-qaeda hanani
was arrested in late 2015
but sources allege orders still intended
to give the money launderer and his
canadian operatives
sensitive information ordis is awaiting
trial
none of the allegations have been proven
in court
there is much more to the story which
sources say is one of the worst
intelligence compromises in canadian
history
global sam cooper has posted it on our
website global news dot ca slash
global national
next the americans still pledging to
protect and defend
president trump
you're watching global national
[Music]
it's always hoped the start of a new
year will mark a new beginning but when
it comes to u.s politics and the
pandemic
we'll have to be patient next week's
inauguration will mark a turning point
america will have a new president but
all the anger that built to a violent
crescendo last week
has not vanished global's mike armstrong
is on the road in america
and he stopped in a town in central
pennsylvania
during the election campaign the trump
signs in lebanon county
outnumbered biden signs 10-1 well two
months later it's about 10 to nothing
the trump signs are meant to send a
message i won't take it down
i'm a big trump supporter and supporter
of freedom and liberty
trump won this county with almost twice
as many votes as biden
it is as they say trump country many are
so convinced of that they won't even
admit biden's going to be inaugurated in
a week
it's not over it's not over
that opinion isn't hard to find in fact
directly across the street jamie boerer
insists trump isn't going anywhere she
admits to following the q anon
conspiracy group and says trump's
staying in the white house we'll have to
wait and find out but i think
something's going to happen god is in
control and
i think god is going to make this happen
at the local park this group tries to
avoid politics
not because someone might get mad at
them but because they themselves might
get carried away
we have a swear jar here i would
really fill it up pelosi has hated him
from the get-go
now the reason we came to this town was
to speak to a gentleman who lives just
up main street
one of only 14 people arrested during
the capital riots last week
inside the capitol building brown has
been told by his lawyers not to do an
interview but we did have a conversation
he says he's still upset about the
election and wanted
his voice heard but now he's nervous and
hoping to avoid jail time
well the riot was a bridge too far for
some steve smith voted for trump in two
elections
and has defended him over and over but
not again
i don't know if you want to call it
inciting violent violence but he didn't
do a whole lot to stop it
smith didn't support the first
impeachment but he understands the
democrats this time
that said for the good of the country
he'd like to see it dropped
there's just too much anger already
prolonging the whole thing he fears
might make it worse mike armstrong
global news
myerstown pennsylvania tomorrow i'll
host an hour-long special about the
future of american politics and the
pandemic
you can watch 2021 what lies ahead
friday on global and that is global
national for this thursday
i'm donna friesen tonight's your canada
is this beautiful scene
at sturgeon creek in winnipeg there are
beautiful places all over canada please
email your canada
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you